the city of Baghdad formed two vast semi
circles on the right and left banks of
the Tigris 12 miles in diameter the
numerous suburbs covered with parks
Gardens villas and beautiful promenades
and plentifully supplied with rich
bazaars and finally built mosques and
baths stretched for a considerable
distance on both sides of the river in
the days of its prosperity the
population of Baghdad and its suburbs
amounted to over two Millions the palace
of the caliph stood in the midst of a
vast park several hours in circumference
which beside the menagerie and Avery
comprised an enclosure for wild animals
reserved for the chase the palace
grounds were laid out with gardens and
adorned with exquisite tastes with
plants flowers and trees reservoirs and
fountains surrounded by sculptured
figures on this side of the river stood
the palaces of the great Nobles immense
streets none less than 40 cubits wide
traversed the city from one end to the
other dividing it into box or quarters
each under the control of an overseer or
supervisor who looked after the
cleanliness sanitation and the comfort
of the inhabitants
[Music]
the water exits both on the north and
the south were like the city gates
guarded night and day by relays of
soldiers stationed on the watchtowers on
both sides of the river every household
was plentifully supplied with water at
all seasons by the numerous aqueducts
which intersected the towns and the
streets gardens and parks were regularly
swept and watered and no refuse was
allowed to remain within the walls
an immense square in front of the
Imperial Palace was used for reviews
military inspections tournaments and
races at night the square and the
streets were lighted by lamps there was
also a vast open space were the troops
whose barracks lay on the left bank of
the river were paraded daily the long
wide enchants at the different gates of
the city were used by the citizens for
gossip and recreation or for watching
the flow of travelers and country folk
into the capital the different
nationalities in the capital had each a
head officer to represent their
interests with the government and to
whom the stranger could appeal for
counsel or help Baghdad was a veritable
city of palaces not made of stucco and
mortar but of marble the buildings were
usually of several stories the palaces
and mansions were lavishly gilded and
decorated and hung with beautiful
tapestry and hangings of brocade or silk
the rooms were likely and tastefully
furnished with luxurious D vans unique
Chinese vases and golden silver
ornaments both sides of the river were
four miles fronted by the palaces kiosks
gardens and parks of the Grandy's and
Nobles marble steps led down to the
water's edge and the scene on the river
was animated by thousands of gondolas
decked with little flags dancing like
sunbeams on the water and carrying the
pleasure-seeking Baghdad citizens from
one part of the city to the other along
the wide stretching
keys they whole fleets a tanker sea and
river craft of all kinds from the
Chinese junk to the old Assyrian raft
resting on inflated skins
[Music]
you